Nóng, tóm gọi hai chi em rồi người nghiên em luôn bán.
Theo bóng xích khỏe với đời sống, phó hỏi mấy lâm dây mùi phút ngày 1 tháng mời,
tổ công tác của các bạn hợp sân, là nhi em vụ tạc khi trên sắc sân,
thách hiện đối tượng có biểu hiện nghi vấn có kìm tra,
có hàng bệnh trong có một tự nhiên lần chứ thả mật khô, nghi lần.
Tính hình giám định, tăng và tù được lập, là MDNB,
ENAK, và MDNB, Bôn Anh, PNAK, có khối lượng là 4 trăm chim miền chỉ trăm bá biệt ràng.
Cô sắc mình, người gây hàng là xương thành đặt,
xin năm 1 diến trăm chim miền, chủ tạc phân vinh tân thành của bình,
người an, cân cứ tài lựa thu thập được,
có quan cạnh sát điều tra công an việc xúc sân,
đến hành khám sát chỗ của đối tượng tại thành của bình,
người an, tạc thời điểm khám sát, có chỉ gái của đặt là xương không khám,
xin năm 1 diến trăm chim miền lâm,
có quan công an đã thu dữ được nhiều hộp,
có tuy nhiên lòng, chế thả mục hô,
có đối tượng khán nhận, đã tìm vô nhập.
Ở sửa đăng bán trên các mạng giá hội từ bệnh cho khách,
chia ra thành những tuy nhỏ, đón thịt tượng đối tượng để sịt cho khách.